die richtige produktiv vor dem komma
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge christmas kraft zusammen
mit komme
es gab in der letzten zeit ein paar was
in letzter zeit in den letzten tagen so
ein bisschen problemchen und zwar die
ersten beiden folgen könnten ja noch
perfekt hier kommen die dritte dann
schon wieder nicht mehr die 4000 oder
ist der 50 die fünfte folge wir wollen
jetzt einfach mal so machen dass wir
jetzt immer abwechselnd hochladen den
wir doch nicht mehr dabei sind der
schafft das irgendwie nicht vom vom
zeitplan vom terminplan
nein das ist eigentlich viel besser weil
der nicht aufrecht gespart werden wir
werden auf jeden fall nicht produktiv
gewesen entweder dabei gewesen wäre
hätte alles gewackelt dass die schnee
und feldwehr abgebrannt komme übrigens
sich fragen wollte bezüglich hero machen
wir hier friedensvertrag weil wir
wollten wurden von stege und von tim von
euch angriffe dann richtig um
ich habe eine rüstung 30 bögen
zauberstäbe und die ganzen barbara
sachen verzaubert
ich habe das nie verändert
ich tue mir gerade auf den horst schöne
gerade auch den ganzen bäumen um ich
frage mich wo du bist komme hat nämlich
die letzte folge alleine aufgenommen und
zwar komme hat er was nicht verstand
eigentlich wollte ich dass wir alle
folgen also zusammen aufnehmen aber es
ging ja nicht anders deswegen wollen
jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen wollen es
einfach mal ein bisschen mehr hier
aufnehmen damit jetzt damit ihr auch
jeden tag deine voll gehabt und nicht
beschweren sollte und das hier ist jetzt
auch dementsprechend nicht part 4 oder
par 3 oder irgendwie sowas an das part 5
sondern es ist halt immer der tag wo
halt welcher tag hat gerade ist er
sollte jetzt gratis der fünfte zwölfter
werden das video seht den jetzt gerade
der tag 5 er kommt in dieser höhle wo
bist du genau wo ich bin war ich geb dir
mal die koordinaten parkett ich bin bei
354 und dabei 500 khalil akil ein chat
geschrieben
us-dollar und ein ausrufezeichen richtig
genau da mal so da bin ich und 541 so
kommt einmal ändert party alter du
bisher relativ weit weg nach manhattan
djokovic illig es gibt dir welche mit
dem man rumfliegen kann diesen voll geil
wo wie was wo bei hexe die jetzt mal die
chocobos die goldenen die kohle nicht
beachten die blauen die blüte blauen
kannst du dich wasser flash wir haben
schon zwei goldene höhe der zeit richtig
hammer kann man die eigentlich panik
wieder klar das machen wir schon seit ca
10 20 30 folgen
geil deswegen das dauert halt ein
bisschen
ich habe zurzeit noch das schwarze das
ist dass hinter dem goldenen also das
ist das was danach davor als das
schwarzes mega schnell kann meter hoch
springen damit hast du nachtsicht
und die hat jetzt einfach immer wie man
die zimt im saal und dann braucht man
noch was ein sattel irgendwie und ich
habe mittlerweile eine chocobo beck also
da kann meint okan sachen aufnehmen
sowieso ein merkmal ehrlich ich sehe
dich komm ich seh dich achter vor
ich habe mir ein paar blöcke geholt das
war eine rüstung ja wir konnten wie
könnte man ja am ende eine
schneeballschlacht ja das machen aber
ich dachte wir könnten doch auch mal
einen schneemann bauen
ich habe hier stimme wie keinen schnee
blöcke machen also das können wir ja
dann trüben bei uns im haus machen
erstmal jetzt hast du ob die koordinaten
vom haus ich weiß nicht mehr wie ja klar
ich habe dass jemand bei mir ist grade
megane stimmen schreibt meine kommentare
aus wo ich heute auch gestimmt hat
beziehen wir sie immer noch stümpfe
hatten nämlich sturmfrei in der schule
das ist nämlich die einzige grund warum
heute noch in folge kommt ich pack da
mal ein bisschen heiser reinemachen mit
dem eisernen rüstung macht dass ich habe
jetzt schon einigermaßen viel und ich
habe auch noch mal ein paar schneebälle
für eine kleine schneeballschlacht oder
das wird geil aber ich glaube ich glaube
man kann leider nicht mit den schnäbeln
dich weg stoppen irgendwie ich glaube
das geht nicht
man kann ich zwar per vaters da passiert
einfach gar nichts ja man kriegt halt
kein ding ja man wird nicht weg
geschubst man kriegt man keinen schaden
das mit schaden deshalb müssen weil
sonst keiner richtig schöne schlacht
machen und so richtig aber sonst immer
so viel obwohl wir das einfach hier
schnee mitnimmt zu hause habe ich das
war ein bisschen sand mitnehmen damit
wie allerdings haben für glas und so
aber haben wir vor der tür aber
verließen wir gerne mitnehmen so ich geh
jetzt auf jeden fall mehr in die höhle
ich ermitteln hier malen eingang damit
du auch da rein findest was wir dann
überhaupt bauen bei uns wenn wir zu
hause sind als du hast doch schon in der
ersten folge richtig viel vorgeschlagen
wir sind aber vielleicht dafür auch neue
ideen
ja auf jeden fall ein schneemann dann
baum weihnachtsbaum eventuell solche
zuckerstangen dann vollständig zerstört
dann was kann man sonst noch schönes
bauen
deine mutter ein stern
ich denke man noch bauen
und deine mutter ich glaube die die
passt nicht jeder auf die welt wohl ich
boah da an wird es unendlich fasste das
war fies so aber du gehst dann die höhle
ich lasse ein bisschen boden scheiße
geld wo die höhle hier ist schon mal ein
bisschen erfahrungen der oberfläche
macht das obwohl kannst auch ich habe
hier irgendwie den falschen weg gewählt
ich schaue mal eben wo ich die höhle
hier finde wenn ich dir habe dann gebe
ich bescheid dann kannst du mitkommen
ich warte jetzt auch noch ein paar mops
die dann irgendwie spawn hier kommen
einfach als ich gespielt habe war
einfach in keinem ob weit und breit zu
sehen und ich habe die ruhe laufen
jedoch nicht es war aber einmal ist
sicher waren waren ja mob stil kommt man
heute eine brücke eine brücke oder
fordert jetzt komme ich die höhle kann
das sein da seht ihr rechts sehen wir
dass da mal rein das richtig viel reisen
natürlich nehmen was der schlucht
varianten eine heftige schlacht habe ich
aber auch schon gesehen
nimm dir auf jeden fall mal eine eisen
spitzhacke mit für diamanten im fall der
fälle und was könnte man sonst noch
gebrauchen ich habe keine eisen
spitzhacke ich hätte jetzt auf eine
ganze reihe machen
ach so ja dann muss das also nochmal
reinschmeißen so wie jetzt auch da
hinten auf spannte erstmal bisschen obst
hast du schon mal vorgehen da komme ich
gleich einfach nach übrigens komme und
damit wir mehr ein thema reden es wurde
mir nämlich häufig in die kommentare
geschrieben wir sollen unser unseren
größten weihnachtsfeier schreiben
ok und komma bitte hier über geratete
hier zu mir gehören also link an dem ihr
erst eben töten hier siehst du mich
damit du den weg auch wenn es nachher
möchte ich sehe dass ich komme gefahr
die menschen töten so hier hinter der
guck mal hier vorne bin ich hallo ihr
rechts daher hier ist der höhleneingang
einfach hier rein laufen ja die größte
und meint die minecraft verhilft wollte
ich schön sein
die größten weihnachtshits von yuma
vergessen geschenk zu kaufen oder so
nils pfingsten nicht vergessen geschenk
sowie ok dann von gehirn weil mir was
echt einfach so dass ich einmal war
komme hier sind zwei änderungen kommen
hier unter diesen 1000 skelette bei mir
sind zwei ändern bei mir die box mich
ich habe nur noch halbes leben anders
tot
wo ist der andere muss der andere muss
der andere an die andere du wirst
sterben omega teleportiert sich mal von
mir weg so jetzt hab ich noch mal geboxt
ok es tot wir haben eine perle noch mal
mit den abnehmern machen
man kann diesen dings sehen
doch diese allerdings kann man das ende
das ging doch mit ende augen oder so ja
dann brauchen wir noch so ein ding
endlich so warte da ist dass das dass
das ist das doofe ist derzeit dass wir
uns nicht allerdings machen können
rucksack im schönen er stimmt schon gar
nicht wenn wir ja auch gefühlte 100
items weniger ich bin komplett schon
voll mein komplettes inventar bestimmt
habe ich nicht hab ich schon alle
gesteckt also ich mache eine kiste und
packte alle sachen die ich jetzt erstmal
nicht brauchen der höhle sowie schnee
oder wie viel eisen hier ist einfach mal
ist unglaublich ist das archiv mit 6 2
nach kreis was fällt mir das ja du
redest ja einfach gar nicht über das
thema eigentlich einreihen wollte es
dazu auch noch sagen ach ja stimme ich
habe gesagt haben stimmt das recht das
war ja du bei mir ist es so dass
großer fehler war dass ich einfach
vergessen hat ein geschenk zu kaufen
für meine eltern ab zwar gekauft aber
für meinen geschwisterkind nicht und die
mir und meine schwester war
dementsprechend traurig laut wie
konntest du nur weil wir heute doch sie
hat mir was gekauft weil ich dann zum ja
gut ich jetzt kaufen nicht okay okay man
also das war auf jeden fall ein großer
fan
dann war einmal ein fall dass unser
stern halt einfach abgefallen ist vom
weihnachtsbaum ok oh meine mutter sagt
gerade ich auf das hört man nicht mehr
aufnahmen die sollte recht nicht dass
wir einfach denn der stein ist wirklich
einfach abgefallen er war irgendwie
komisch obendrauf befestigt oder so
und er ist wirklich einfach runter
gefallen dann direkt in die krippe und
alles kaputt gegangen und ob also total
stumpfe sache sehr gut
diese fast keiner mitbekommen hat so
hier unten ist nix der damals die
höllischen ausgeraubt und ich komme hier
ich habe gerade die schlucht gefunden
war mal hier oben hat den geheimgang von
anderer seite
ich bin aber hier war noch keiner oder
ist egal kommt dass in die schlucht
gemeinsam unterwegs kommt mein größter
weihnachtsfeier war auf jeden fall wo
ich damals meinen pannen beamten kaufen
sollte
und ich hab auch dann eingekauft und der
war dann aber ziemlich groß so ich
dachte er passt locker da in die stuben
aber nix da passte gar nicht wieder
einfach eingelegt oder wie wir haben
dann unten am stamm bisschen was
abgesägt und die spitze auch eingesteht
abgekürzt so dass der baum oder nicht
die schäden aus ja das wird jetzt will
ich auch so bei größter weihnachtsfeier
und ansonsten keine ahnung wo ich meine
was gibt's da sonst noch also ich habe
schon von vielen stories guetta ist der
weihnachtsbaum so halb abgefackelt aber
jetzt auch noch das war nicht bei mir
irgendwann mal der fall
da hatten wir mal recht viel habe ich
auch schon jetzt ab dass die ig wir
haben halt jetzt neuerdings immer so
damit hast du hin da kann ich brillen
höchsten schmelzen
nein wir hatten damals wirklich war so
old school mäßig richtigen kerzen am
baum und so etwas heutzutage ist das
macht das keiner mehr mittlerweile
machen wie es aber auch so dass normale
lichterkette daran habe da kann es
natürlich auch passieren dass die
einfach überhitzt und dann irgendwie
anfängt zu brennen aber nicht so wild zu
einer hohen chance wie das dahin die
kerzen dann wenn man das alleine lässt
glaubt mir wenn ich die anbauen würde
die word anfragen zu briten rund vier
wochen ist einfach so aber du bist
einfach komme handwerklich ist einfach
einpacken nur die besten ketten sind der
idee wenn eine lampe kaputt geht oder
engler al gore zwei lampen so dass dann
die komplette kette einfach gar nicht
mehr geht das jahre hätte das ist und
das ist unsere hirne eine lampe ging
nicht alles andere kaputt da fragt man
sich natürlich welche ist dann geht man
jede lampe durch versucht dieses diese
lücke zu finden aber man findet die
einfach nicht weil man halt gefüllte
lambda durchgeht und irgendwann sich
sagt war ich hier nicht schon mal auch
nur schwer merken sei komisch
doch da hat merkel in drei minuten ist
die folge schon wieder vorbei weil die
folgen hätte ich heute noch online gehen
ja natürlich
dann kannst du denn eigentlich wieder
aufnehmen kann jetzt mal material talk
wir könnten gleich rein theoretisch noch
mal einem anschluss direkt aufnehmen
warum das so ja gut wenn meine folge im
rennen ist kann wäre dann genau das kann
man machen
die ränder tanz 20 minuten danach
perfekt aber direkt in der folge für
morgen hat dem morgen safe auch noch
eine folge am nikolaustag oster schön da
soll ja auch noch der sturm richtig fett
abgehen wie heißt der star ich hab den
name chris christie oder nein nein okay
dann nicht christi welches über christi
ich schaue mal eben nach dass ich jetzt
hier wird ich glaube dass dieses kritik
ich folge reisen essen nach was wollte
ich jetzt habe ich danach und warschau
eine kurzzeit gedächtnis von seiner ein
tag sklavisch kommen nicht aber wer
denkt sich an solchen eigentlich immer
frauen haben so stimme es immer
frauennamen welches mit boxen
ja klar dort ist alle punkte hat du
willst so kämpft man heutzutage auf mehr
erfahrung wohl wifi level hast du ich
habe gerade fünf level 16
ist das nicht unglaublich ich habe 16
einfach ein bisschen lover vielleicht
mitnehmen ansonsten aber sie machen ich
mein wasser sehen sind langweilig können
wir machen aber ich hab kein eimer
ich habe auch keinen crafting table von
der ich habe auch kein fleisch
hackfleisch das doch 100pro noch fleisch
das war vielleicht habe ich noch ein
labor nehmen so viel kohle mit ne das
ist unglaublich weil wir wären ja auch
kohle um nachher die ganzen sachen zu
beraten
genau ich habe hier schon eine reisen
und so wichtig was hast du ein steak
reisen
ja ich wollte gerade was zu essen geben
richtig geil wenn die richtige produktiv
von dem koordinaten steht dahin
ich warte hier auf dich ich habe aber
auch keine level geklaut oder sowas doch
ein gedicht schreibt ihm eine gewisse
schuld du brauchst mich immer wieder ein
verbesserter koordinaten bitte einfach
unter ich hab dich zweimal geboxt du was
direkte hoffeld also jetzt im hip hop
projekt dann auch laufen beim kritik das
wird so geil wenn wir uns im hier
projekt jetzt krieg gibt
wir haben wir planen jetzt eine taktik
gegen euch weil wir gegen euch sind aber
ich habe euch ab metall und so sage ich
mal wegen die stege und tim sind ja auch
über ein portal zu uns gekommen deswegen
ich weiß nicht die wollten das
vielleicht auch ausnutzen kurz mit den
portalen aber ich werde das auch nochmal
ansprechen dass es nicht über portale
darf weil ich möchte nicht dass der
krieg direkt nächste folge ausbricht
weil wir uns noch vorbereiten wollen hat
wir haben auch taktik und alles jaja
taktiken genau
ja meine lieben freunde ich bin hier
noch auf dem weg zu dir ich mache jetzt
einfach eine kiste hier
ich glaube hier ist die schlucht kannst
aber ich hab gar nicht so viel holz für
eine kiste ich habe keine nahrung mehr
ich kann nicht mehr sprinten
ja wenn du bist ja gleich da oder geht
ich bin in fünf folgen da wo du bist bin
bei 275 und 38
ich bin rein gehen hast du denn holz mit
gehabt dort sehr doch du hast du dich
aber ich möchte das holz kriegen nicht
die anderen sachen da ich weiß jetzt
nicht welche richtung das ist ist er so
ich hasse koordinaten ich konnte mich
zurecht und wie grüne richtig blöd warum
nicht gleich ich form als holz da unten
ich mach das jetzt einfach kurz so ok
welche ganzen sachen können jetzt nicht
mehr hiervon ich wollte jetzt eben eine
künstlerin der steigeisen caroni jurist
duo kam von mir die das eisen
schwertkampf von mir gehörte glaube ich
sogar mir fünf davon knochen meine wie
produktiv sechs pfeile spitze gehört ihm
das könnt ihr das könnt ihr das könnt
ihr ja soeben ihre kisten packt seine
sachen da rein
so eine kiste für dich und eine kiste
für mich der name hahahaha endlich so
dann packe ich als eben meine ganzen
sachen rein okay wie komme ich da jetzt
leben darunter verdammt das wird auch
noch was komme ist paco ok meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst einen daumen hoch da ich sagen
gerade noch kommen sachen ein comeback
angekommen kann jetzt ebenen fazit der
folge ziehen und kann sich dann mal kurz
entschuldigen für seine dummheit und
auch das thema kann ich mir mal in die
letzte wort überlasse ich dann doch
lieber dir ja leute wenn es euch
gefallen hat würden wir uns definitiv
über einen daumen runter freuen
nein wenn ihr dann bewertet das video
wie ihr wollt
morgen kommt die folge bei komme dann wo
er wiederkommt an seine sachen holt und
mich sagen teams übrigens komm ich hab
noch zwei tipps von dir bei mir in der
truhe weil deine darüber voll okay alles
klar hole ich mir ab ok dann würde ich
sagen
bis zum nächsten mal macht es gut und
schön